rusia segura que está evacuando a los
civiles de la planta de acero de
mariupol se trata de 19 adultos y 6
menores de 14 años pero su paradero a
estas horas es
desconocido todavía quedan más civiles
en esa planta de acero y también
combatientes heridos que esperan ser
evacuados urgentemente esa zona se está
bombardeando pero el ejército ruso se
están moviendo hacia ceap orilla hacia
ese flanco sur de esta guerra y en la
zona noreste en jarquín el ejército
cráneo está recuperando posiciones pero
se están acumulando tropas rusas en esa
frontera y se espera una ofensiva en los
próximos días la guerra en este país se
centra en la batalla del donbass en
donges y lugares donde se están
produciendo la mayoría de combates y los
más intensos ya estas horas se intenta
evacuar a las personas que continúan
allí atrapadas además hoy se ha
producido también un ataque con misiles
en odessa uno más ha sido contra el
aeropuerto y una de las pistas de
despegue y aterrizaje
totalmente destrozado